>> THE U.S. PRESIDENT POSSIBLY
WORKING FOR THE RUSSIANS.
POSSIBLY.
>> Laura: NOW DESPITE
IRRESPONSIBLE COVERAGE LIKE THAT
THROUGHOUT THIS ENTIRE
INVESTIGATION CNN CARL
BERNSTEIN, STILL DINING ON
WATERGATE WAS DEFENDING THE
MEDIA'S ROLE IN ALL OF THIS.
>> THE MEDIA, THE PRESS HAS DONE
ONE OF THE GREAT REPORTING JOBS
IN THE HISTORY.
LET'S LOOK AT WHERE THE
DISINFORMATION MISTAKES AND THE
LYING HAS COME FROM.
IT HASN'T COME FROM THE PRESS.
IT'S COME FROM THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW LAURA
LOGAN, SARA CARTER FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, GREAT TO HAVE YOU
ON, YOU RECENTLY MADE HEADLINES
FOR MAINSTREAM MEDIA AND
OVERWHELMING LIBERAL BIAS.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON THIS
MUELLER OBSESSION AND THE
RUSSIAN COLLUSION OBSESSION EVEN
AFTER THE TWO COYEARS OF
INVESTIGATION, 500 WITNESSES
CALLED ET CETERA, ET CETERA.
>> Laura: LAURA I'VE BEEN A
JOURNALIST OVER THREE DECADES
AND I HAVE TO SAY, I FEEL
ASHAMED.
WHEN I WAS LISTENING TO THE
CLIPS THAT WERE PLAYING, IT MADE
ME FEEL ASHAMED.
THIS IS A TERRIBLE MOMENT AS
JOURNALIST.
I'VE BEEN SAYING SEVERAL YEARS,
ACCOUNTABILITY BEGINS WITH US.
PEOPLE ACROSS THIS COUNTRY ASKED
ME ALL THE TIME ABOUT FAKE NEWS
AND HOW WE GOT TO THIS POINT
WHERE SO LITTLE TRUST IN THE
MEDIA.
YOU SEE IT PLAYING RIGHT IN
FRONT OF YOU RIGHT HERE.
I WILL GIVE YOU ONE OF THE MOST
FRUSTRATING EXAMPLES FROM THE
BEGINNING, DO YOU REMEMBER WHEN
EVERYONE WAS MAKING FUN OF THE
PRESIDENT FOR SAYING HE WAS
ATTACKED DURING THE TRUMP TOWER
WAS BEING WIRETAPPED AND WE GOT
LOST IN A CONVERSATION ABOUT
SEMANTICS AND LATER, THE
PRESIDENT'S CAMPAIGN AND
TRUMP TOWER WERE BEING BY THE AE
TRUMP TOWER WERE BEING BY THE AC
TRUMP TOWER WERE BEING BY THE A,
TRUMP TOWER WERE BEING BY THE AA
TRUMP TOWER WERE BEING BY THE AD
TRUMP TOWER WERE BEING BY THE AE
TRUMP TOWER WERE BEING BY THE AA
TRUMP TOWER WERE BEING BY THE AT
TRUMP TOWER WERE BEING BY THE AY
WHAT HE MEANT AND THE PRESIDENT
WAS RIGHT.
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES WERE
LISTENING TO HIS ACCOUNTINGS.
IT IS NOT SURPRISE ME JOURNALIST
WERE NOT READY TO STAND UP AND
SAY, WE WERE WRONG AND THE
PRESIDENT WAS RIGHT, THAT IS NOT
SURPRISING, BUT IT DOESN'T MAKE
IT ANY BETTER.
IT'S NOT A FINE MOMENT FOR
JOURNALISM AND JOURNALISM AS A
I'VE DONE ALL MY LIFE.
>> Laura: WE NEED JOURNALIST
TO ASK TOUGH QUESTIONS AND HOLD
EVERYBODY ACCOUNTABLE EQUALLY.
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN A FAVOR OF THAT
MOLDING TRUMP ACCOUNTABLE, BUSH,
OBAMA, CLINTON ACROSS THE BOARD.
THAT IS WHAT WE DO FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
SARAH, TONIGHT ON CNN, GIULIANI
APPEARED WITH CHRIS CUOMO AND
THEY ARE OLD BUDDIES BUT THIS IS
KIND OF BEEN INTERESTING MOMENT
THAT TOUCHES ON SUSPENSION.
>> YOU GUYS AT THIS NETWORK HAVE
TORTURED THIS MAN WITH TWO YEARS
AND NOBODY IS APOLOGIZED.
BEFORE WE TALK ABOUT
OBSTRUCTION, APOLOGIZE TO THAT
COLLUSION.
>> NOT A CHANCE, NOT A CHANCE.
>> OF COURSE YOU WILL NOT.
>> Laura: NOT A CHANCE, THREE
WORDS.
AND I WILL GO BACK TO MATT,
EXHAUSTIVE AND HE DOCUMENTED
JUST HOW BADLY THIS TRAJECTORY
WENT FOR THE MEDIA.
AND NOT FOR A MOMENT, NOT A
CHANCE.
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU?
>> Sara: IT TELLS ME NOTHING
HAS CHANGED FOR NOW FOR THE
MEDIA AND IT IS DISAPPOINTING,
LAURA.
LOOK WE HAVE TO LOOK BACK AT THE
BEGINNING DURING 2016 CAMPAIGN.
LOOK AT THE COVERAGE.
HOW THEY TREATED
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HOW THEY TREATED THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WHO SUPPORTED
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY TALKED ABOUT DEPLORABLE,
THEY LAUGHED, THEY SAID NO WAY,
IT'S TRUMP, DONALD TRUMP TO BE
ELECTED PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY DID NOT BELIEVE IT FOR ONE
SECOND.
THERE WAS A VISCERAL HATE ALL
OVER WASHINGTON, D.C.
ALL I COULD HEAR IS THE BARS
AROUND TOWN, NO WAY HE WILL GET
ELECTED.
I WILL BE SURE TO WRITE A COLUMN
AGAINST THIS.
ANY AMERICAN WHO VOTES FOR HIM
IS AN IDIOT.
I HEARD THAT OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
I WOULD SAY TO MYSELF KEEP
WRITING THAT AND HE WILL GET
ELECTED.
ABSOLUTELY.
ONE THING WE HAVE LEARNED FROM
THIS RIGHT NOW AND WE COULD SEE
IT WITH RUDY GIULIANI IS THAT
THEY DON'T WANT TO BACK AWAY
FROM THIS.
EVEN WHO WROTE A STORY ABOUT
MICHAEL: BEING A FRAUD, THERE IS
NO PROOF OF IT AND MICHAEL COHEN
HAS ALWAYS DENIED IT.
THEY WON'T BACK AWAY FROM THE
STORY.
THIS IS WHY PEOPLE ARE ASKING TO
RETURN PULITZER PRIZE.
IT IS NOT BASED ON FACTS.
>> Laura: LAURA COME UP
BUZZFEED RAN THE DOSSIER IN
JANUARY 10TH BEFORE TRUMP COMES
AND SO TEN
DAYS BEFORE HE TAKES THE
OATH OF OFFICE, THEY DROPPED
THAT, UNSUBSTANTIATED,
UNCOOPERATED AND THAT TURNS OUT
TRUMP CAMPAIGN PAID FOR ASSEMBLY
AND THAT GOT THIS WHOLE THING
GOING.
JAMES COMEY RAN WITH IT AND A
LACK OF CURIOSITY LAURA ON THE
PART OF THE MEDIA, WHAT WAS THE
MOTIVATION?
>> Lara: I MEAN COME I THINK
YOU ARE BEING KIND WHEN YOU SAY
LACK OF CURIOSITY BECAUSE
CURIOSITY THE MORE FUNDAMENTAL
QUALITY FOR ANY REAL JOURNALIST.
WE ARE ALL NOSY, RIGHT?
TO ME IN A TIME REPORTERS NOT
BEING NOSY THAT'S WILLFUL.
IT DOESN'T TAKE A GENIUS TO
FIGURE OUT THE FIRST THING YOU
HAVE TO ASK ABOUT BUZZFEED
DOSSIER ALL THE THINGS WE KNOW
ABOUT THE DOSSIER, FOR EXAMPLE
THE ONE CANDIDATE IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION PAID
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
AMERICAN CITIZENS TO TRAVEL TO
RUSSIA AND MEET WITH SERVING
AGENTS OF VLADIMIR PUTIN IN
INTELLIGENT SERVICES WHO GAVE
THEM, YOU KNOW, INFORMATION, MIS
THEM, YOU KNOW, INFORMATION, MIE
THEM, YOU KNOW, INFORMATION, MID
INFORMATION AS IT TURNED OUT
OPPOSITION CANADA AND THE
ELECTION.
AND THE INTELLIGENT AGENCIES AND
FED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
AND FED TO THE MEDIA.
OF COURSE, IT WAS THEN LEAKED.
THIS WAS USED BY THE COURTS AND
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES TO USE THE
POWER OF OUR INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES AGAINST AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
THIS IS A POWER THAT IS MEANT TO
BE USED TO PROTECT THIS COUNTRY
AGAINST FOREIGN ENEMIES, NOT
AGAINST ITS OWN CITIZENS.
THAT IS ACTUALLY A CRIME IF THAT
POWER IS MISUSED.
AND NO ONE HAS BEEN HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT.
AND THAT IS WHY THE MICHAEL
COHEN WAS THE FIRST CASUALTY OF
THIS.
HE WAS THE MAN TO EXPOSE IT.
>> Laura: AND FLYNN, ALL OF
THESE PEOPLE GOT WRAPPED UP IN
ALL OF THIS.
I'M TELLING YOU, THE ENTIRE